bonjour à tous la France va devoir vivre
avec la menace terroriste c'est ce qu'a
déclaré manuel Vals le Premier ministre
ce matin à la sortie d'un conseil de
défense restreint le Premier ministre
qui a également appelé à la solidarité
qui a demandé aux Français de rester
fidèle à l'esprit du 14 juillet cette
nuit déjà et bien François Hollande le
président de la République avait été le
premier à prendre la parole après le
terrible attentat de Nice pour annoncer
notamment la nouvelle prolongation de
l'état d'urgence pour 3 mois la semaine
prochaine mardi très exactement sera
présenté un projet de loi en conseil des
ministres et puis mercredi et jeudi
prochain et bien le Parlement débattra
le président de la République a
également annoncé le renforcement de
l'action en Syrie et en Irak mais
comment faire pour lutter contre les
réseaux djihadistes et leur action en
France et bien c'était sur cette
question que c'était déjà interrogé une
commission d'enquête sénatoriale l'année
dernière une comm mission d'enquête
présidée par la sénatrice udi UC
Nathalie Goulet et dont le rapporteur
était le sénateur PS Jean-Pierre suur
les sénateurs avaient remis 110
propositions avec notamment l'idée de
contrôler systématiquement les
frontières de l'espace Schengen il
également de renforcer le renseignement
pénitentiaire afin de palier les
carences de la loi et bien ce son une
table ronde dans le cadre de ces travaux
que je vous propose de voir ce matin
messieur les ambassadeurs consuls
mesdames mes chers collègues euh j'ai le
plaisir de vous accueillir aujourd'hui
pour une une table ronde qui était
prévue de longuees dates euh dans le
cadre de la commission d'enquête que je
préside et dont Jean-Pierre Sueur est
ici le
rapporteur cette commission d'enquête
est composée de membres de la commission
des affaires étrangères et de la Défense
et de membres de la commission des lois
euh le contexte international est
évidemment extrêmement important et et
le le la commission d'enquête portait
sur l'organisation de lutte contre les
réseau djihadiste en France et en Europe
cette table ronde a donc été programmée
il y a plusieurs semaines de cela avant
le drame qui a endeuillé Copenhague en
fin de semaine dernière et Madame
l'ambassadeur de euh du Danemark
arrivera tout à l'heure mais
naturellement nous avons tous une une
pensée pour les victime de ce de ce
drame épouvantable
alors si vous le voulez
bien nous allons procéder de la façon
suivante vous allez messieur nous nous
donner un petit
aperçu de la législation en place dans
vos pays d'une législation
additionnelle si cela a été le cas
récente parce que chacun des pays a dû
s'adapter à la à la menace on a on a
tous eu à à avoir probablement des
mesures dans chacun de nos pays et ce
qui ce qui serait intéressant aussi
c'est surtout les problèmes que vous
rencontrez je pense pouvoir dire pour
travailler déjà ce sujet depuis un
moment que nous sommes tous en face du
même genre de de problématique
c'est-à-dire un l'efficacité relative du
tout
répressif de la propagande sur Internet
et comment et comment on essaie de
l'endiguer et ça aussi c'est une
question que nous avons tous à nous
poser puisque nous sommes tous soumis
euh à cette nouvelle règle de l'Internet
et à ces à ses méfits et puis les
problèmes spécifiques que vous pouvez
rencontrer dans vos pays enfin
euh les questions d'équilibre
entre les mesures sécuritaire et et la
liberté puisque cette cet équilibre
entre sécurité liberté est toujours un
équilibre extrêmement compliqué à
trouver reste
évidemment la question de la coopération
européenne et c'est aussi extrêmement
important bienvenue
excellence je vous en prie Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur c'est aussi extrêmement
important que nous puissions en parler
et que là aussi vous puissiez nous nous
donner un certain nombre d'indications
et de préconisation pour que pour que ce
rapport puisse être tout à fait utile et
que vous puissiez éventuellement en être
bénéficiaire également puisque je crois
que nous sommes
tous dans la même dans la même
problématique et tous avec la même
volonté de lutter contre contre ces
réseaux donc le point de la législation
les mesures nouvelles l'équilibre
sécurité
liberté les problèmes spécifiques
éventuellement du droit d'asile parce
qu'il y a un certain nombre de pays où
ça se pose avec plus d'acquité que
d'autres donc tout ça sont les
problématiques euh auxquelles euh sur
lesquels nous souhaitons nous souhaitons
vous vous entendre la coopération
européenne évidemment et et le PNR
puisque ce personnal name record que
chacun appelle de ses vœux euh dans les
parlements nationaux et et brusquement
qui devient un problème quand les mêmes
parlementaires ou en tous les cas les
parlementaires de de même groupe
politique se trouve au sein du Parlement
européen alors est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
trouver une solution à à cette question
et éviter un peu de de de schizophrénie
donc voilà voilà un peu le le cadre le
cadre de cette de cette audition qui est
une audition publique qui est
retransmise sur Public Sénat ce qui
explique un certain nombre de points
liés notamment aux questions de
renseignement ne seront pas évoquer sauf
si sauf si vous avez des points
particuliers à évoquer puisque en étant
en audition ouverte c'est un peu plus
compliqué de de parler et de débattre
des questions de de renseignement
et et donc je
vais je vais passer la parole au
rapporteur qui souhaite évidemment vous
accueillir madame la Présidente je n'ai
vraiment rien à ajouter à ce que vous
avez excellemment
dit je voulais simplement ajouter
peut-être si vous le permettez à nos
ambassadeurs et à notre consul général
une question complémentaire nous sommes
tous dans une situation angoissante
difficile puisque nous sommes témoins en
direct de ce qui se passe et de ce qui
s'est passé encore ce weekend au
Danemark et nous avons le sentiment que
nous devons non seulement le sentiment
mais la certitude que nous devons
travailler ensemble donc j'ajoute
peut-être une question c'est quelles
sont les mesure de coopération urgente
entre les différentes
nations que vous envisagez ou auquel
vous pourriez souscrire pour lutter
contre ce fléo du
terrorisme merci monsieur le rapporteur
alors j'ai oublié de vous indiquer que
cette audition était ouverte aux autres
membres du Sénat qui souhaitaient venir
y participer que les présidents des
groupes d'amitié ont été conviés et que
je dois excuser tout particulièrement
notre collègue barizakari qui vient de
subir une une opération et que j'ai
promis d'excuser absolument clairement
euh avec votre permission nous allons
commencer par entendre Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur de de
Grande-Bretagne
euh si vous voulez bien excellence nous
donner un petit aperçu de la
réglementation dont la la toute dernière
proposition de loi qui a été qui a été
déposée qui est en qui est en débat y
compris un point qui nous occupe tout à
fait c'est c'est l'interdiction du
retour sur le territoire pendant 2 ans
car si ces djadistes repentis euh ne
reviennent pas chez vous ils seront chez
nous et donc c'est une mesure qui nous a
un peu qui nous a un peu interpellé que
vous allez sûrement nous expliquer je
vous donne la parole pour une dizaine de
minutes ou 15 minutes vous avez la
parole
excellence ça marche bon madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup excusez-moi
encore une fois d'être d'être un peu en
retard d'abord permettez-moi de dire que
nous nous sommes tous confrontés par la
même menace euh nous avons vécu ces
moments extraordinaires à Paris quand
Paris et la France était magnifique en
réponse à ces attentats le 7 janvier on
a vécu aussi les drames en Belgique qui
a heureusement évité un attentat sérieux
et
puis les action terroriste à Copenhague
le weekend et ça peut arriver dans dans
tous nos pays pays nous avons eu une
première expérience en 2005 quand nous
avons eu des attentats très graves sur
le métro londonien avec une cinquantaine
de morts qui nous a quand même fait
réfléchir à ce moment-là sur les les
gens élevés chez nous radicalisés chez
nous et qui sont passés à l'acte
terroriste et ça a
beaucoup
incité notre gouvernement à
euh augmenter les les crédits pour les
les services de renseignement euh et de
changer notre loi aussi pour faire face
à cela alors je vais je vais vous faire
part brièvement de des certains éléments
de nos lois et je vais répondre en
faisant ça aux questions que vous avez
posé
euh d'abord avant de passer au aux lois
un mot sur le contrôle parlementaire et
judiciaire des actions du gouvernement
nous avons chez nous maintenant une
commission euh d' de notre Parlement des
deux chambbres de notre Parlement
commission sur le renseignement avec un
statut
euh légal et avec des pouvoir important
de d'auditionner et de contrôler et
d'avoir accès euh à tous les papiers
nécessaires sous conession bien sûr de
de secret d'état et nous avons des juges
qui contrôlent les AC des services de
renseignement et les actions des
ministres en autorisant les
actes des services de renseignement pour
assurer un contrôle clair et avec des
publications de rapport au
Parlement alors sur sur la
législation à notre avis il faut
absolument combattre
le problème euh en amont euh
c'est-à-dire euh le prévenir euh
combattre la radicalisation aux sources
avant de d'arriver à traiter le problème
les symptômes de problème dans les
actions terroristes alors pour ça euh
nous
avons beaucoup évolué notre législation
et notre pratique euh par exemple pour
combattre la radicalisation dans les
prisons euh en mosquée et sur
l'Internet prenons le cas de notre
programme channel c'est un programme de
partenariat entre la police et les
associations au niveau local pour
encourager les voies dans les
communautés de s'élever
contre la
radicalisation l'islam
radical aider les personnes à risque de
d'éviter la radicalisation et promouvoir
l'action au niveau local dans les
prisons nous avons organisé par les
services de notre home office euh
beaucoup plus d'information sur les
détenus susceptibles de radicaliser les
autres ou les prisonniers susceptibles à
radicalisation et nous avons une gestion
adapté pour se impliquer dans les
activités
extrémistes nous faisons beaucoup
d'attention aux amoniés au moniés dans
les prisons pour s'assurer qu' présente
quand même une vision modéré de l'Islam
et de corriger les
distorsions venant des gens qui sont en
train de radicaliser dans les prisons il
y a vigilance nécessaire des agents dans
les prisons pour identifier les
problèmes suffisamment tôt d'agir et un
problème d'éducation pour les
prisonniers qui cherchent à savoir les
informations
euh vraies euh par exemple sur la
théologie de
l'islam 2è gisement d'activité très
important après action contre la
radicalisation en prison c'est réduire
la propagande des islamistes en ligne là
c'est bien sûr une un domaine qui évolue
très rapidement mais on se rend compte
que daesh et les autres groupes
islamistes utilisent très savement les
instruments de l'Internet pour
euh promulguer leur messages et attirer
les gens vulnérable vers la Syrie et
l'Irak et la
radicalisation alors il faut identifier
rapidement ce contenu ces sites web il
faut agir avec les acteurs du web pour
les supprimer pour cela nous avons au
niveau national développé
des des contacts des liens très étroites
avec les les acteurs du web euh avec les
gens qui qui fournissent les plateformes
sur le web euh souvent hors Europe
d'ailleurs pour pouvoir agir rapidement
et supprimer les sites web euh
susceptibles à
radicaliser nous avons une cellule
spécialisé euh dans notre gouvernement
euh qui est comparable à ce que vous
avez en France je pense ça s'appelle
Faros en France nous avons l'équivalent
pour perfectionner ce
partenariat volontaire entre le
gouvernement et les acteurs du
web ça fonctionne assez bien chez nous
et nous avons des interrogations sur une
proche plus législative au niveau
européen euh on n pas sûr que c'est
nécessaire ou que ça marcherait
nécessairement bien avec les les
fournisseurs de services pasé hors de
l'Europe alors étant donné l'urgence de
l'action
contre l'extrémisme propagande de
l'extrémisme sur le web à notre avis il
faut agir surtout et et
premièrement en terme de partenariat
d'accord volontaire entre les
gouvernements et les fournisseurs de web
et ça nous avons nous avons beaucoup
fait depuis plusieurs
années nous avons aussi dursi notre
législation récemment vous avezit
référence à ça pour obliger les
fournisseurs de servicees en ligne de
stocker les données euh et aussi pour
nous aider à attribuer
euh les domaines du web à des individus
pour euh des raisons de de sécurité et
de de maintien de l'ordre pour donner
accès
eu à l'identité des individus euh
euh par rapport à leur domaine sur le
web alors alors passons des des actions
de prévention vers les actions euh
contre les personnes déjà radicalisé
ou pour empêcher ces gens de partir
euh vers la Syrie et l'Irak ou de les
contrôler dès leur
retour notre nouvelle législation
adoptée il y a quelques semaines au
Royaume-Uni contient des mesures pour
euh h
durcir les mesures les instruments euh
pour la police d'agir contre les gens
qui sont en train de partir par exemple
on peut retirer les passeports à la
frontière pour permettre
euh les enquêtes policières sur les
individus on peut faire d'échéances de
nationalité c'est-à-dire le ministre
peut décider euh de retirer la
nationalité britannique de quelqu'un au
cas où cette personne a aussi une
deuxième nationalité pour éviter la
patride bien sûr mais une fois déchu de
nationalité britannique la personne peut
être soumis à des contrôles
d'immigration et et si nécessaire s'il y
a l'information nécessaire expulsion du
territoire national pour retour au pays
de
départ alors si la personne fait valoir
de leur droit euh
par exemple
pour expliquer que ils ont face à une
menace dans le pays concerné pour le
retour au pays sous article 3 par
exemple
du convention européen de droit de
l'homme nous avons mis en place un
système de
d'assurance vis-à-vis certains
pays pour servir devant nos tribunaux
pour montrer que on
peut expulser éloigner des personnes à
ces pays sans risque à leur liberté et
droits et nous avons maintenant un
réseau d'assurance avec un certain
nombre de
pays par exemple Algérie par exemple
Éthiopie Jordanie Liban Maroc qui nous
permet de expulser des gens de retourner
les gens vis-à-vis de ces pays-là avec
des accords en place que nos tribunaux
acceptent
protège les libertés les les droits de
ces personnes-là et bien sûr nous
cherchons d'élargir ce réseau de pays
pour permettre précisément le retour des
personnes qui sont tant infraction chez
nous qui n'ont pas le droit de rester
chez nous tout ça est soumis bien sûr de
de droit d'appel à nos à nos tribunaux
plus élevé et surtout un tribunal qui
est spécialisé pour écouter les procès
où les données de renseignement les
données secrées sont en cours et comme
ça on peut traiter et et juger les
devant les tribunaux les cas qui
nécessitent la présentation de documents
classifié vous avez fait référence
madame la Présidente à un nouveau
instrument dans notre notre législation
récente qui a certainement a eu des
échos dans les médias ce que nous
appelons un temporary exclusion order un
mandat d'exclusion temporaire qui permet
au ministres d'interdire le retour au
territoire britannique d'un citoyen de
nationalité britannique pour nous
permettre de mettre en place des un
contrôle dès l'arrivée de cette
personne la référence dans la presse de
2 ans euh c'est c'est une mal c'est mal
compris en fait c'est c'est c'est c'est
pas du tout l'intention de ce mesure de
laisser quelqu'un pour 2 ans en dehors
du Royaume-Uni un personne de citoyens
britanniques la la durée de la mesure
peut peut la mesure peut durer 2 ans
mais normalement ce serait une question
d'heur quelques heures pour permettre
aux forces de l'ordre britannique de
s'organiser pour le retour de cette
personne qui pourrait poser un danger
euh à l'ordre public mais ce sera très
rapide et bien sûr euh dès que cette
personne-là est est euh arrêtée
contrôlée par exemple en France ou are
pays voisin nous allons nous préparer
pour le le recevoir dans les dans les
délais qui qui se mesure en heure plutôt
que que plus long que ça et nous
n'imaginons pas qu'il y aura beaucoup de
cas non plus mais c'est c'est un c'est
un une disposition euh qui permet de
d'être prêt à prendre le contrôle d'une
personne qui qui arrivve et et dont nous
avons euh raison de penser qui pose un
risque à notre autre publici alors
c'était pas très bien compris mais
c'était ça euh l'idée que nous nous
sommes mis et c'est le l'objectif de ce
mesure alors je ne prendrai pas plus de
temps maintenant je suis sûr que vous
aurez des des questions à nous tous à
proposer
mais à notre avis les instruments pour
lutter contre ce menace doiTent évoluer
au même niveau au même tempo au même
temps que la menaisse elle-même et ça
s'applique surtout dans le domaine de
l'Internet où l'utilisation des réseaux
sociaux
euh des réseaux numériques par les
terroristes évolue très rapidement et
nous devons être en mesure de suivre ça
et de de de d'éviter qu'ils utilisent le
web contre nous alors les domaines que
nous devons
euh favoriser prioritiser en notre avis
au niveau européen c'est bien surûr le
le PNR vous avez fait référence à ça à
notre avis un PNR au niveau européen
très important et qui doit permettre
l'échange de données sur les vols
intrauropéens qui qui est absolument
essentiel euh les é change de données en
temps réel entre les forces de l'ordre
les agences de sécurité absolument
essentiel
aussi améliorer nos
techniques de répérer les communications
des terroristes cacher dans les réseaux
sociaux davantage de coopération des
fournisseurs d'accès au Web pour nous
aider à supprimer les sites ou indiquer
les communications suspectes entre
terroristes tout ça pour nous fait
l'objet de des priorités que nous devons
mettre en œuvre au niveau européen
j'espère que ça au moins déblé un peu le
terrain madame la Présidente oui je vous
remercie beaucoup Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
excellence je vais vous poser une ou
deux petites questions complémentaires
mais en attendant je voulais saluer
l'arrivée de Madame
l'ambassadeur ringelson du Danemark vous
exprimez madame toutes nos condoléan et
et aussi notre soutien notre grande
solidarité pour ce qui s'est passé à
Copenhague la semaine dernière et et
vous dire
que nous sommes tous nous sommes tous
danois aujourd'hui comme vous avez été
Charlie il y a quelques mois quelques
semaines déjà et que cette accél et
français aussi et que cette
accélération de la
violence et ce dérapage incontrôlé nous
rend plus que jamais citoyens du monde
nous sommes CoPt nous sommes Charlie
nous sommes nous sommes aujourd'hui
victimes d'un ennemi que nous ne
contrôlons évidemment pas et ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui n'est qu'une une
très modeste pierre en tous les cas pour
montrer à ceux qui voudront bien le voir
que nous sommes tous unis pour lutter
contre ce terrorisme merci en tous les
cas d'être d'être
venu monsieur Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
avant de passer à à la séance de
question global j'ai juste deux petites
précisions à vous demander euh
vous avez parlé de prévention terme que
je n'avais pas utilisé parce que j'avais
dit le tout répressif n'est pas n'est
pas suffisant moi j'ai une question sur
l'organisation de de l'Islam en
Grande-Bretagne qui évidemment est très
différent de ce qui se passe en France
j'avais rencontré le procureur général à
Londres et et qui m'avait notamment
expliqué l'obligation des prêches en
anglais en ce qui concerne le le
contrôle finalement des mosquées est-ce
que vous nous pouvez nous
parler très rapidement de cette
organisation de l'islam et comment vous
coopérez avec la la communauté ou les
communautés puisque puisqu'on sait que
l'Angleterre de ce point de vue là est
une est une
mosaïque donc c'est c'est vraiment très
important parce que vous savez que
récemment le gouvernement français a
développé un programme stop jihad sur un
dotg ce qui évidemment est pe poser
aussi un certain nombre de de
difficultés de crédibilité est-ce que
vous pourriez juste nous nous parler un
tout petit moment de l'organisation de
de de vos rapports avec la la les
communautés musulmanes
britanniques absolument madame la
Présidente je ne suis pas un grand
expert vous avez raison de signaler que
il n'y a pas une communauté
musulmane ni chez nous ni dans dans les
autres pays parce que c'est pas
structuré comme ça c'est pas hiérarchisé
alors il y a tout un série de d'org
qui représente des courants dans le
monde musulman il y a bien sûr les imams
dans les mosquées aussi depuis depuis
les attentats de 2005 nous avons
développé tout un structure
gouvernementale pour garder le contact
avec ces gens-là pour développer le
dialogue pour encourager comme vous
dites les imams de
s'informer pour pour mieux lutter contre
contre les distorsions de l'islam c'est
surtout le en prison aussi et il y a un
salut de notre gouvernement qui euh agit
beaucoup en ligne et en communication
avec les organisations chez nous pour
essayer de construire ce qu'on appelle
un narrative qui est contre le
radicalisation extrême alors je ne dis
pas que nous avons moyen parfait c'est
pas par la moyen législatif c'est plutôt
par la coopération la coordination
volontaire avec les différentses acteurs
de la commun musulmane je vous remercie
beaucoup je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur des
Pays-Bas on va s'il vous plaît
excellence voilà choisis le bon bouton
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs chers
collègues c'est vrai que on a connu une
début 2015 terrible bien sûr à Paris et
ensuite à Copenhagen et y a quelques
jours mais bien sûr hélas le fléo n'est
pas nouveau notre collègue britannique a
rappelé Londres et je suis sûr que mon
collègue espagnol va rappeler ce qui
s'est passé à
Madrid ce qui prouve bien sûr la
nécessité de de parler de de tout cela
de de coordonner nos actions et c'est
pour cela que je suis ici aujourd'hui
avec grand plaisir pour vous expliquer
un tout petit peu comment ça se passe au
Pays-Bas euh afin de renforcer la
collaboration entre les différents
services au Pays-Bas le service de
renseignement et de sécurité nationale
eu mon pays a choisi en 2005 déjà de
nommer un coordinateur national de la
lutte contre le
terrorisme en 2011 la mission de ce
coordinateur national et bien sûr son
service ont été élargis avec la gestion
de crise avec la cybersécurité et la
sécurité nationale et ils sont sous la
responsabilité du ministre de la
sécurité et de la
justice je dois toutefois souligner que
le coordinateur opère de façon
stratégique les opérations se font au
niveau des divers services de police
bien sûr de
renseignement et de la
gendarmerie c'est au sein de cette
service ce service de coordination qu'a
été élaborer le programme d'action ce
qu'on appelle approche intégrée du
djihadisme
ce programme a été présenté à notre
Parlement en août 2014 et pour ceux qui
s intéresse j'ai ici des copies en
anglais j'espère bien qu'on va faire
aussi une traduction en français bien
sûr ce programme d'action qui est un
travail évolutif comme d'ailleurs ça
vaut pour tous les travaux qu'on fait
dans ce genre contient 38 mesures visant
trois choses la protection de la
démocratie et l'état de droit la lutte
contre et l'affléblissement du mouvement
diihadiste au Pays-Bas et enlever le sol
nourricier de la
radicalisation et tous ces programmes
d'action sont en fait axés autour cinq
groupes de
disposition le premier groupe c'est de
réduire les risques de combattants
djihadistes le deuxème thème c'est
intervenir en cas de départ pour le
djihad le troisième c'est la lutte
contre la
radicalisation le 4e c'est les réseaux
sociaux et le 5e c'est l'échange
d'information et de coopération un point
que vous avez souligné vous-même et j'y
reviens un peu plus tard dans ma
présentation alors le premier point
réduit le risque des combattant
diadiste tous les actes terroristes les
préparations aux actes terroristes
tombent surous le coup de la loi comme
décrit notre code pénal une enquête
judiciaire est ouverte pour toute
combattant dihadiste qui se joint un
groupement terroriste la participation à
une lutte terroriste où le fait de
suivre l'entraînement terroriste est
punissable une trentaine d'enquêtes
judiciaires sont actuellement en cours
impliquant aux alentours d'une
soixantaine de personnes les détenus
soupçonnés deux ou condamnés pour des
actes terroristes sont placés dans des
quartiers spécifiques à l'intérieur de
la prison appelé quartier
terroriste le code pénal néerlandais
offre plusieurs possibilité de placer
sur surveillance longue les combattants
qui reviennent au Pays-Bas et maintenant
et on a parlé déjà de cela dans la
présentation de mon collègue britannique
aussi au Pays-Bas le gouvernement est
actuellement en train de voir de quelle
façon la Loi sur la citoyenneté
néerlandaise peut-être étendue aux
possibilité de retirer la citoyenneté
néerlandaise dans le cas de délits
terroristes cela ne vaut que pour les
personnes ayant plusieurs nationalités
il est à mentionner que la plupart des
combattants ont à côté de leur nation
néerlandaise une autre nationalité
souvent non
européenne les combattants n'ayant pas
de nationalité d'un pays membrre de
l'Union européenne seront déclarés non
désirables et
expulsables et y a aussi les mesures
administratives les combattants qui
rejoignent réseau diihadistes sont
inscrits sur la liste nationale de
terrorisme et tous leurs moyens
financiers seront gelés toute service
financier sera fusé et tous ceux aussi
la famille et des amis qui mettent de
l'argent à leur disposition sont
passables d'une peine une cinquantaine
de personnes sont touchées par cette
mesure
actuellement deuxè thème intervention en
cas de départ pour le djihad lors deun
suspicion d'un départ pour le djihad une
enquête judiciaire est ouverte et si la
suspicion se précise la carte d'identité
ou le passeport est déclaré expiré et
l'entourage du combattant est mis au
courant 52 passeports ont été signalés
comme appartenant à des combattants
djihadistes et dans le C de départ pour
le djihad pressenti dans lequel le
mineur est impliqué des mesures de
protection d'enfants sont
prises 3è thème c'est la lutte contre la
radicalisation la loi pénale
néerlandaise ne connaît pas deit
d'apologie du terrorisme mais par contre
l'incitation à la haine en public est
inscrite dans le code pénal
l'incitation à la haine envers des
personnes du fait de leur race religion
au conviction sexe orientation sexuelle
handicap est passible d'une peine
pécuniaère ou une peine de
prison le recrutement de personnes pour
le djihad ainsi que l'incitation la
haine et l'appel à violence dans un
cadre extrémiste sont pénalement
punissables ce qui facilite et propage
de la propagande djihadiste seront
dérangés dans leurs activités que ce
soit sur Internet ou ou pas l'approche
est ici aussi bien pénale
qu'administrative les facilitateurs
reconnus seront inscrits sur la liste
national de terrorisme les prêcheurs qui
incitent à la haine et à la violence qui
proviennent des pays etant l'obligation
d'obtenir un visa avant d'entré au
Pays-Bas se verront refuser ce visa il
existe une coopération étroite avec les
mosquées néerlandaises et les
iment la radicalisation dans les prisons
là nous avons décidé de de placer des
personnes souçonnées ou condamnées pour
des actes terroristes dans des quartiers
spécifiques comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure les quartiers terroristes ces
quartiers existent déjà depuis 2005 et
ils offrent 13 places dont environ 85 %
sont occupé pour l'instant et bien sûr
uns objectifs de ces quartiers est
d'aller à l'encontre du recrutement et
de la radicalisation dans les
établissements
pénitentiaires la sélection de tenu se
fait sur la base des compte-rendus de la
police du ministère public et du service
des établissements judiciaires ils sont
répartis dans deux établissements
pénitentiaires et sont largement équipés
pour éviter toute activité terroriste
une détenu qui est placé dans le
quartier terroriste est soumis à un
régime individuel c'est le directeur de
l'établissement qui fixe dans quelle
mesure le détenu peut participer à les
activités individuelles ou communes ce
faisant il évalue sur la base d'une
estimation de risque si le détenu peut
avoir des contacts avec des cétenus les
contacts externes se font de façon
restreinte et conformmément aux lois en
vigueur ces contacts externes sont
d'ailleurs soumis à des contrôles strict
en ce moment même on explore la
possibilité si le régime individuel peut
avoir une forme encore plus sur mesure
c'estci enfin d'accompagner mieux le
retour de Cees détenus dans la
société
maintenant quelques mots sur la
prévention un des éléments clés dans
tout ce que ce qu'on doit faire dans le
cadre de la prévention il existe au
niveau local dans les communes des
concertations
multidisciplinaires régulières dans
lesquelles prennent part les
organisations communales et la police
locale qui entretiennent de nombreux
contacts avec d'une part les
représentants formels des différents
groupes religieux de population et
d'autre part les leaders informels ces
contacts permettent de ressentir ce que
les populations vivent et constitue un
important indicateur quotidien un
avantage non négligeable de cette
approche est-ce qu'il est relativement
facile d'obtenir des informations venant
de l' venant de l'intérieur de ces
communautés et de plus elle permet
d'exercer une influence certaine de
façon indirecte ou directe par exemple
arrestation de imam qui tiennent des
prêches incitantes à la
haine le service de notre coordinateur
met à disposition c'est très important
des experts pour les communes qui sont
classées prioritaires dans cette
problématique ces communes reçoivent en
plus une subvention pour la mise en
place d'un réseau d'instances de
personnes clés formel et informel
évidemment toujours avec l'objectif
d'améliorer la signalisation précoce et
de rendre la stratégie plus
efficace
des concertations régulières sur
l'approche locale ont lieu au niveau
national bien sûr sous la présidence du
ministre de la sécurité de la justice
avec le coordinateur les services de
renseignement et le ministre des
Affaires sociales le ministre de
l'Intérieur et les maires de communes
les plus touché le programme d'action a
fait également élargir le nombre
d'intervenants dans les établissements
scolaires et ça concerne la formation
pour les enseignants et la mise à
disposition de programme
éducatif je voudrais souligner quelques
euh points euh nationaux euh qui sont
plus récentes euh on a créé un centre
d'experts le 1er janvier alors il y a
quelques semaines et ce centre d'experts
se veut un support pratique pour les
communes et les professionnels dans le
signalement précoce et l'approche la
radicalisation 2èe point on a créé un
permanence national
extrémisme les citoyens ainsi que les
professionnels peuvent de façon anonyme
signaler toute forme d'extrémisme les
signalements sont transférés vers les
instances qui les prennent ensuite en
charge et troisième point c'est un point
de soutien national pour la famille va
être favorisé il s'agira d'une
organisation de réseau indépendante qui
entretient les liens étroites avec
d'autres organisations sociales ce qui
permettra devenir en aide aux familles
dont membre s'est radicalisé est parti
combattre ou qui en revient ce point
soutien do égal pouvoir appuyer les
communes alors trois points assez
concrets qui ont qui ont vu le jour
récemment par les billets des réseaux
locaux et nationaux on renforce le
contred-discours et on s'efforce à
consolider la résilience contre la
radicalisation et les tensions dans la
société ainsi on organise dans les
communes concernées des des réunions
d'information sur l'enroulement et les
dangers en ligne le gouvernement
néirlandais favorise par tout le Moyen
le débat sociétal sur les valeurs de
l'État de
droit 4è point dans cette approche sont
les réseaux sociaux la lutte contre la
propagation du contenu dihadiste
radicalisant et incitant à la haine pour
cela une équipe spécialisée de la Police
Nationale néerlandaise lutte contre le
contenu djihadiste
cette équipe informe le ministère public
des expressions punissables qui
circulent sur Internet de plus on
explore les possibilités de prendre de
dispositions avec les opérateurs
Internet pour pouvoir bloquer de façon
efficace les contenus djihadistes les
opérateurs Internet qui malgré des
avertissements continuent de faciliter
les organisations djihadistes listées
seront poursuivies soit selon la
directive européen en lien avec le
règlement de pénalisation néerlandais
datant de 2002 soit selon réglementation
nationale qui doit encore être
élaboré 5e et dernier point échange
d'information et la
coopération au niveau local le
gouvernement soutient l'approche locale
comme je l'ai déjà expliqué il y a
quelques minutes au niveau national la
coordination entre tous les services
nationaux est renforcé une priorité est
donnée à la détection des réseaux di
et leurs facilitateurs par les suivi des
flux financiers ainsi que la détection
des mouvements de voyage
djihadiste à cette fin les services de
renseignement la police la douane et
autres services concernés doivent
pouvoir consulter les données des
compagnies aériennes au niveau
international bien sûr lors de son
intervention devant le Conseil de
sécurité des Nations un le Premier
ministre appelé à un respect strict des
sanctions hisiennes concernant le
terrorisme 2ème point les Pays-Bas
préconisent de restreindre les flux
financiers terroristes dans un cadre
européen 3è point le mois dernier nous
onons participé d'ailleurs comme la
France à une réunion à Londres sur les
combattants étrangers et nous
participons également à la réunion qui
aura lieu demain à partir de demain à
Washington et finalement madame la
Présidente je me permets d'attirer votre
attention sur une conférence au niveau
ministériel sur le cyber qui aura lieu
au Pays-Bas le 16 et 17 avril à lae
évidemment le cyber djihadisme est
également à l'ordre du jour et ça
évidemment c'est pas étonnant j'en
viiens maintenant à la fin de ma
présentation comme vous l'avez pu
constater nous efforcerons comme
beaucoup d'autres pays ici présents de
combattre le dihadisme le plus
efficacement possible nous onons tous
besoin les uns des autres et aussi pour
des raisons que je exposé aujourd'hui
euh pour les détails de mes propos je
voudrais me référer programme d'action
que je vous ai montré bien sûr je
pourrais mettre à votre disposition tous
nos informations tous les renseignements
qu'on a euh qui seront utiles à rédiger
votre rapport merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup juste une toute
petite précision lorsque vous parlez de
services financiers vous voulez dire les
allocations chômage les allocations
familiales ce genre de chos d'accord
comme comme nos voisins belges
d'ailleurs ou d'accord je vous remercie
beaucoup je vais vous donner la parole
Excellence Monsieur l'Ambassadeur de
d'Espagne à
vous merci madame la présidente monsieur
le
rapporteur mesdames les sénatrices
monieurs les sénateurs je Cai vous
remercier de votre invitation pour
aborder avec vous en ce moment crucial
pour la sécurité l'Europe et pour notre
mode de vie les mesures adoptées par mon
pays sur la question qui nous occupe cet
après-midi le terrorisme international
d'origine jihadiste intègre intègre de
nouvelles formes d'agression qui se
caractérise par de nouveaux instruments
de captation de formation et
d'endorinement dans la haine l'objectif
est de les utiliser de manière cruelle
et abérente contre tous ceux qui selon
leur idéologie extrémistes et violentes
sont qualifiés d'ennemis à abattre ce
terrorisme se carérise pour la vocation
d'expansion internationale à travers des
leaders charismatiques qui diffusent
leurs messages et consignes sur sur
Internet et en particulier grâce à
l'utilisation de réseaux sociaux leur
message d'une extrême cruauté prétend
provoquer la terreur parmi la population
et il lance un appel à leurs adeptes du
monde entier afin qu'il qu'il commettent
de attentat les destinataires de ces
messages peuvent être des individus qui
une fois alisé et endoctriné tente de
perpétrer des attaques contre les
objectifs signalés notamment des
attentat
suicide nous non moins important est le
phénomène de combattants terroristes
déplacés qui décide de rejoindre les
organisations terroristes
internationales ou leur filial sur les
scènes de l'un des conflits armés auquel
participent les jihadistes
particulièrement la Syrie et l'Irak en
ce moment ce phénomène cons
l'une de des plus grandes menaces pour
la sécurité de toute la communauté
internationale et de l'Union européenne
en particulier en effet ces derniers se
déplacent pour se former dans l'
manement des armes acquérir la capacité
nécessaire et pour se mettre aux ordres
de groupes terroristes les attentats de
Paris et de Copenhague et les détention
postérieure des terroristes djihadistes
dans plusieurs pays de l'Union
européenne illustre la nécessité de
maintenir de façon permanente la la
lutte contre le terrorisme dans l'agenda
des priorités aussi bien au niveau
interneeuropéen la lutte contre le
terrorisme SiGe un effort à long terme
soutenu et en étroite coopération avec
les partenaires européens et les
paystiers l'Espagne pays victime du
terrorisme pendant 40 ans est
particulièrement bien placé pour prendre
des initiatives dans ces combats qui
aujourd'hui affecte tous les pays
européens je ne voulais je ne voudrais
pas manquer cette occasion pour
remercier une fois de plus l'inestimable
coopération du gouvernement successif de
la France dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme de aujourd'hui et recement
enéenti dans ces moment historiques nous
sommes mieux dotés pour relever les
défis présents grâce à cette expérience
de coopération
conjointe cela exe la mise en vre de
mesures concrètes et immédiates au
niveau interne qui permett de combattre
l'émergence du phénomène objet de
l'analyse de cette commission et requier
également la participation et la
coopération au niveau international en
particulier au sein de de l'ONU et
d'autres institutions
multilatérales dans les domaines
européens nous avons besoin d'une action
commune renforcée qui compte avec les
concours de tous les membres des loué
ainsi que lesurs institutions et agences
et des états
important je vais procéder maintenant à
faire une analyse globale des mesures
adoptées au niveau européen et ensuite
j'expliquerai les mesur adopté au niveau
interne
espagnol niveau européen la Déclaration
de Paris du 11 janvier dernier a une
grande valeur dans la mesure où elle
contient un ensemble détaillé de mesures
adopté dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme contre les combattants
djihadistes ceux qui reviennent et les
loup solitaires l'analyse de la menace
c'est clair et les mesures et solutions
sont identifiées désormais il est
nécessaire de procéder à l'application
des mesures de façon effective et
immédiate en premier lieu parmi les
mesures adoptées de façon immédiate
l'Espagne considère qu'il est de la plus
haute importance de compter avec un PR
registre national des des passagers et
et P
européen il semble que les parlements
européens se sont montrés plus souples à
cet égard suite aux attentats de Paris
en vue de l'adoption de cette importante
mesure vers la fin de l'année en
cours nous soutenons également la
modification législative du code
frontière Schengen pour permettre un
contrôle systématique aux frontières
extérieures des personnes qui jouissent
du droit à la liberté de circulation
dans les bases de données y compris les
SIS et d'autres systèmes me sans que
cela n'affecte les flux au
franchissement des frontières par
ailleurs l'Espagne apporte son soutien
aux propositions soumise par la
présidence de loué en vue
d'intensifier la lutte contre le trafic
illicite d'armé de
feu l'Espagne dirige les plans
opérationnels qui traitent de cette
question dans le cyclle politiqu de Loué
contre la criminalité organisée est
grave cette question RV un intérêt ire
pour l'Espagne de ce fait elle s'engage
à ébré intensément avant de contriuer à
mettre en marge de mesur coordonnées et
efficace actuellement cette action
compte avec la participation des 13
États-membres et je profite de mon
intervtion pour lancer un appel à
d'autres États afin qu'il nous
rejoignent l'Espagne recherche également
une
homogénéisation de niveau d'alerte
terroriste dans l'Union européenne les
but de cette mesure et de produire les
effets suivants lancer à nos citoyens un
message clair et cohérent de
coordination au sein de
l'oué faire savoir aux terroristes notre
disposition conjointe pour les
combattre apporter une valeur ajoutée
aux organismes nationaux compétents afin
d'évaluer la menace terroriste de
faciliter ainsi l'adoption de mesures
pour la
contreécarer nous partageons les mêmes
en ce qui concerne l'importance du rôle
d'Europol dans la lutte contre les les
contenus terroristes sur les
net nous sommes aussi conscients de la
nécessité de maximiser de renforcer ses
capacités comme un point de référence
enfin dans les domaines d'Internet il
est nécessaire de trouver des solutions
communes et de freiner la radicalisation
et l'utilisation abousive d'Internet à
des fins terroristes l'Espagne considère
très positive la poursuite de
l'initiative impulsée par la Commission
de réunir dans un forum commun les États
membres les institutions et les
représentants du secteur de l'industrie
d'Internet des initiatives comme les
projets check de web compte avec notre
participation et soutien l'Espagne
appuie aussi tous et chacun des projets
interpris dans la lutte contre la
radicalisation comme les projets SS C
cat équipe consultative de communication
stratégique sur la Syrie selon ce cycle
en
anglais en définitive face aux attentats
et à la menace terroriste terroriste
nous devons réagir avec des solutions
effectives je suis persuadé que la
mesure de l'action politique est
l'immédiaeté de et l'efficacité des
solutions apportter c'est à C barê que
nous mesurons nos opinions publiques et
nos pays amis
dans cette perspective l'Espagne
demandera à la présidence tournante de
l'oué que lors de la prochaine réunion
du Conseil
ja justice et affaires intérieures de 12
et 13 mars un point soit inclus dans
l'agenda concernant la révision de
l'application de de ces mesures et que
les coordinateurs antiterroristes
présente une actualisation de l'avancée
et de la mise en œuvre des actions
approuvées
je vais me référer aussi brièvement au
niveau
espagnol l'expérience de la lutte contre
les terrorisme en Espagne nous a permis
de compter avec avec une législation
pénale efficace pour répondre au
terrorisme de bande
organisé comme comme ils ont été les ta
ou les crapau des groupes terroristes
dirigés par un ou plusieurs leaders avec
une structure organique claire une
répartition des rôles à l'intérieur de
l'organisation et une hiérarchie définie
et assumée par les individus intégrant
les groupes
terroristes la réponse pénale au
terrorisme s'articulit de ce fait dans
la sension de ceux qui appartenaient et
agissit aujourd'hui et collaborer avec
les organisations et groupes
terroristes l'axe du traitement pénal du
terrorisme était donc de définir
l'organisation où les groupes
terroristes il identifié et identifier
des actions les actions commises par
ceux qui les intégrés ou d'une certaine
manière apporter leur
collaboration le code pénal ne doit en
aucun cas perdre de vue cette
identification des conduites articuliier
autour des organisations ou groupes
terroristes mais il est évident que les
nouvelles menace et SiGe l'actualisation
de la réglementation et de tenir compte
du phénomène du terrorisme individuel et
des action qui qui constitue la
principale préoccupation de la
communauté internationale actuellement
la lutte contre le terrorisme est en
Espagne une affaire d'état qui dépasse
les division politiques entre les deux
principaux partis de du gouvernement
dans la ligne de l'accord pour les
libertés et contre le terrorisme signé
par le présidents il y a quelques années
par les présidents atnar et les leaders
de l'opposition à l'époque Monsieur
Zapatero à l'an 2000 le président de
gouvernement d'Espagne Mariano Rajoy et
le leader de l'opposition secrétaire
général du Parti socialiste monsieur
Sanchez ont signé le 14 janvier de cette
année un pacte d'État contre le
jigadisme son objectif est d'adopter la
loi une loi organique par la voi
d'urgence qui introduise les
modifications nécessaires au code pénal
pour pouvoir faire face aux nouvelles
modalités du terrorisme qui inclu des
actions telles que celles du loup
solitaire les combattants de retour la
formation passive et
l'autoradicalisation par les netes en
plus d'être nécessaire pour doter l'état
des instruments juridiques requis par
les succès de cette lutte les mesures
législatives en cours répondent aussi
aux C jugence de la résolution 2178 du
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies du
24 septembre 2014 les actions
terroristes auxquelles se réfère en
détail la résolution
2178 constitue les principal facteurs de
nouvelles menacees que le terrorisme
international pose aux sociétés
ouvertes menace qui prétend de mettre en
péril les piliers de l'État de droit et
la cohabitation
démocratique parallèlement en Espagne
des mesures ont été prises pour éviter
la sortie des combattants digadistes et
pour neutraliser la menance de ceux qui
reviennent aussi bien que sur le plan
législatif préventif coopérationnel dans
les domaines du législatif les ministres
de l'Intérieur et de la justice
travaillent depuis longtemps sur les
nécessaires réformes législatives pour
affronter les phénomènes des combattants
gigadistes un phénomène terroriste
différent de celui qui
traditionnellement a ci notre pays et
qui Reard l'adapation de la
réglementation à ces formes spécifique
d'ajustement dans le domaine de la
prévention
les au mois de mars du
2012 a été adopté les stratégie
intégrale contre le terrorisme
international et la radicalisation il
comprend quatre plans parmi lesquels il
convient de souligner les plans stratég
national de la lutte contre la
radicalisation violente qui sera
approuvé prochainement par le Conseil
des ministres ce dernier ce dernier
définit pour l'Espagne un système
intégral d'action qui permet
l'observation l'évaluation et le
traitement de la radicalisation et et de
l'extrémisme violent dans leur ensemble
avec une approche
multidisciplinaire sur le plans
opérationnelles des mesures ont été
prises
moyennant un plus grand contrôle des
types de délits qui apportent des
indices sur des futures actions
terroristes comme les activités de
prosellitisme les financement la
provocation ou l'apologie du terrorisme
les contrôles et la surveillance des
combattants de retour et des possibles
candidats à se déplacer dans les zone de
conflit la surveillance dans les prisons
les contrôle des centres où pourrait se
produire la radicalisation les enquêtes
sur Internet les opérations de police
contre les réseau de recrutement et les
détentions des combattants et de ceux
qui
reviennent dans les domaines juridico
légal les ministèr de l'Intérieur à
travers d'un groupe de travail
législatif et dans la ligne des
initiatives entreprises dans des pays
voisins comme le Royaume-Uni la France
l'Allemagne ou la Belgique et étudie
depuis des ans la possibilité
d'introduire des réformes de
réglementation en la matière en termes
généraux ces éentuels mais sûr
affecteraient plusieurs réglementations
comme les codes pénal les codes de
procédures pénal la loi sur les
étrangers les codes civils et d'autres
lois et
concerne principalement des questions
telles que la formation passive
l'autoradicalisation lou solitaire
l'incitation à commettre et l'apologie
des actes terroristes grâce aux
nouvelles technologies et les
combattants de retour eu non exécution
d'une interdiction de sortie ou d'entrée
sur le territoire national les
principaux éléments de ces amendements
euh sont euh long à raconter moi je
crois que je vais m'arrêter ici parce
que j'ai déjà consommé un be bout du
temps et et évidemment je me tiens à
votre disposition madame la Présidente
pour les questions qui soni pertinentes
merci merci beaucoup Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je ne doute pas qu'il y
ait ensuite beaucoup de questions je
vais passer la parole à Madame
l'ambassadeur du Danemark madame vous
avez la vous avez la la
parole merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente sénateur distingués chers
collègues merci beaucoup de m'avoir
invité pour cette table ronde
aujourd'hui je suis très très sensible à
cette
invitation permettez-moi madame la
Présidente de tenir un discours
peut-être un peu atypique nous vivons
des journées
attipiques je voudrais d'abord exprimer
ma profonde reconnaissance et mon
émotion face à la solidarité de la
France envers le envers le Danemark
suite aux attentats terroristes ce
weekend merci merci
beaucoup l'ambassadeur de France au
Danemark Monsieur François simret
présent au centre culturel où la
première fusillade a eu lieu a encarné
le symbole du très fort basculement de
la société danoise que c'est lâ attentat
en caé arrivé simplement à vélo à la
Danoise il est ensuite évacué en
véhicule
blindé le message de votre ambassadeur
magnifique pour nous les Danois est
clair restez sur vos vélos en autre
terme conserve votre société ouverte et
démocratique il est maintenant l'heure
desunir au Danemark il n'y a pas de
doute que les jours à venir seront
difficiles nous devons maintenant
essayer de comprendre ce qui nous est
arrivé la police travaille toujours
intensivement pour faire avancer
l'enquête mais il est très important que
nous nous eff faion de continuer
à vivre comme nous l'avons toujours fait
nous les savions déjà mais nous avons
maintenant la réelle preuve que nous
aussi nous avons des nombreux
ressortissants qui sont tentés par la
cause du diidisme au Danemark et les
théoristes doivent naturellement être
punis c'est très clair mais il y a aussi
ceux qui l' peut peut-être encore sauver
dégrifter
l'extrémisme le le gouvernement danois
veut tendre la main à ceux qui
s'engagent sur le mauvais chemin nous
devons leur offrir le moyen de revenir
au sein de notre
société comme vous l'avez pu le lire
dans la presse française il y a quelques
semaines la ville danoise d'ahous a
depuis 2007 lancé un
dispositif pionnier dans la prévention
de la radicalisation connue sous le nom
de modèle
Arus je tiens à préciser qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'un remède miracle mais simplement
d'un modèle qui a réussi dans cette
ville danoise de 300000 habitants nous
nous insp
et apprenons continuellement des
expériences des autres pays aussi
pressent dans notre lutte contre le
terrorisme au
Danemark madame la Présidente
Cendant en tant que danois il faut se
poser une question la question du
paradoxe un pays comme le Danemark qui
dispose d'une politique d'intégration
ambitieuse
pionnière une politique des répression
tout à fait
efficace une économie en règle avec par
exemple un taux de chômage très bas y
compris parmi les jeunes ce pays
encontre malgré cela une crise causée
par les
caricatures en 2005 ce pays connaît
malgré cela le trè nom membre le plus
élevé des rétocissant allant combattre
euh euh proportion proportionnellement à
sa population forign Fighters ce pays et
malgré cela la cible des sanglant
atentas comme nous venons comme nous
venons d'en faire l'expérience
pourquoi bien entendu c'est une question
que nous nous posons tous et depuis
quelques temps et qui nous revient
encore et encore il n'existe pas des des
réponses formelles même officielles mais
j'aimerais vous décrire à titre tout à
fait personnel mon pays dans sa
structure de base car dans cette
description se trouve peut-être
peut-être des éléments de
réponse permettez-moi de porter votre
attention sur deux points en particulier
le libéral et
l'implicite le Danemark est un pays
extrêmement libéral pas dans le sens de
l'orientation politique même les
sociau-démocrates sont libérals chez
nous mais en tant que philosophie de la
vie notre Constitution s'apparente plus
à une texte poétique que
juridique comparé à la plupart des
autres pays notre législation est minime
et quand nous légiférons ce n'est
délibérment jamais dans le détail mais
plutôt des grandes lignes
d'orientation sauf bien sûr lorsqu'il
s'agit des législation de l'Union
européenne mes excuses au Danemark
quasiment tout est permis au Danemark on
a le droit d'être nazis fond mentaliste
fou pourquoi parce que notre expérience
nous jusqu'ici montrer que le pouvoir de
l'argument est le seul qui puisse
convaincre et seulement en convaincant
dans un débat libre et chez nous c'est
un débat très très libre même
quelquefois rude vous saveztu tout
peut-être regarder borgon c'est du shak
c'est du Macbeth chez nous au Danemark
mais seul seul dans un débat libre que
les gens par eux-mêm vont chier le
Danemark nous avons deux expressions qui
résument cette mode de vie tous deux
formulé par un de pèr de notre
Constitution un prêtre et poète il
s'appelle
frédéricvi en
danois
ça de divinité nordique suulissant le
mal et le bien le mal a tout autant que
le bien le droit
d'exister le deuxè
estque Chrest humain d'abord chrétien
ensuite c'est ainsi que la version
danoise du christianisme devient
l'humanisme
les second trait le second trait de
caractère est plus difficile à décrire
la culture danoise est
implicite tout comme notre législation
ne réglemente pas le détail les règles
du jeu commune parmi nous danois ne sont
non plus explicité
ou que ce soit la façon dont nous nous
comportons les uns vers les autres nous
la apprenons au sein de la famille et
dès le plus jeune âge en Cardie c'est
très jeune c'est à partir de 6 mois
crèche ou Martinel et jusqu'à l'école
nous l'apprenons à travers le jeu l'âge
moyen d'entrer à l'école des enfants
d'OA et des 7 ans pour les filles VO 8
ans pour les garçons ils sont un peu
plus
tardiv nous nous l'apprenons de plus à
travers une éducation où les compétence
sociale occupe la place centrale non pas
qui est le meilleur élève mais qui est
le meilleur camarade les écoliers
travaillent travaillent en groupe les
doués et les faibles côte à côte l'idée
des compétitions avec les notes
n'apparaît que bien plus tard autour des
saisons car arrivé à cet âge on sait
comment se comporter et cette
connaissance est transmise à travers
l'osmos venons de l'extérieur notre
notre de vie peut non se non seulement
paraître très exotique mais aussi très
très difficile à
décodé un exemple pourquoi nous toutons
nous au Danemark et nous appelons-nous
tous par notre prénom même avec Sa
Majesté la Reine gr tout en étant
extrêmement pudique vis-à-vis de notre
vie privée paradoxe
ou encore pourquoi avons-nous l'un des
taux de productivité les plus élevés au
monde mais n travoillons quasiment
jamais ça veut dire la journée de
travail s'arrêtant typiquement à 16h ou
17h ou plus
tard comment réussir dans la société
danoise si les règles sont si
secrètes je pense que la prochaine
exposition du musé du con lit devra
devrait être sur le Danois la Nation
Secrète nous ne devons pas nous refaire
loin de lo mais peut-être simplement
comprendre à quel point nous sommes
exotique merci de m'avoir accordé la
parole et si vous voulez savoir
plus de détails sur le modèle d'ous je
suis préparée aussi merci Madame
l'ambassadeur je crois que plus que
jamais on a envie d'être danois après
vous avoir après vous vous avoir entendu
il y aura je pense une une série de
questions évidemment je vais passer la
parole maintenant à Monsieur le le
consul d'Allemagne monsieur vous avez
vous avez la
parole madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs excellence euh
mesdames et messieurs euh à mon tour je
vous présente maintenant en bref euh les
législations antiterroristes qui
existe actuellement en Allemagne il
inclut des projets de loi et d'autres
champs d'action dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme je commence avec le le droit
pénal matériel euh les règles pénales
préscrites dans le code pénal sont sont
un pilier important de la lutte contre
le
terrorisme il prévoit que certains actes
préparatoire en vue d'actes de
violence constituant une menace grave
pour la sécurité nationale peut faire
l'objet d'une sanction pénale aussi la
formation l'appartenance ou le soutien à
des organisations terroristes nationales
ou étrangères sont également passibles
de peine
un article du du code pénal vise
principalement à définir le caractère
répréhensible du séjour dans un camp
d'entraînement terroriste il précise que
des actes au stade
préparatoire notamment la détention et
l'utilisation d'armes à feu d'explosifs
ou d'autres substances dangereuse de
même que le fait de former ou d'être
formé à utilisation de ces objets ou
substances ainsi que leur fabrication
acquisition ou détention sont aussi
passibles de
peine la même chose vaut pour réunir
réceptionner ou fournir des fonds dans
ce
contexte
euh selon un autre article du code pénal
c'est 89B si vous voulez il est en outre
interdit de nouer de des relations avec
une organisation terroriste dans
l'intention d'être formé à l'utilisation
d'armes à feu d'explosif ou de
substances
dangereuses et un autre en plus
finalement interdit la diffusion par
exemple par Internet d'information tel
que des modes d'emploi pour fabriquer
des explosifs et
autresengin d'après d'autres articles du
Code pénal il est défendu
de on Pouret disons de protéger contre
les organisations terroristes
particulièrement
dangereuses créer une telle organisation
en être membre la
soutenir recruter des membres ou des
sympathtisants constitue des éléments
matériels
d'infraction et l'article 129 9 B du
code pénal précise que cela vaut aussi
pour les organisations situées hors du
territoire
fédéral d'autres règles du code pénal je
veux pas les énumérer toutes tous mais
quand même c'est quelques-uns aussi
doivent être pris en compte euh dans les
affaires euh lié au terrorisme comme par
exemple l'incitation à la haine raciale
apologie de la violence propos
outragent pour une communauté religieuse
ou de penser ou aussi l'interdiction de
blanchimement
d'argent à part ça il y a un aussi un
projet de loi dans le cadre de la
transposition de la résolution 21
61 du Conseil de sécurité des Nations
unies l'Allemagne s'apprête à rendre
possible de sanction les personnes
souhaitant quitter son territoire afin
de participer à des actes violents grave
à l'étranger ou d'être formé dans ce but
euh le projet de loi adopté par le
gouvernement fédéral le 4 février 2015
donc tout récemment prévoit pour se
faire l'ajou à l'article 89a d'un autre
acte préparatoire en en vue d'un acte de
violence constituant une menace grave
pour la sécurité nationale à savoir le
fait de voyager avec une intention
terroriste cette loi prévoit en outre
que le financement du terrorisme même
par de petites sommes deviennent un
nouvel élément constitutif d'infraction
reprépréhensible donc ce projet de loi
garantit que toutes les formes de
financement du terrorisme seront
désormais sanctionné de manière
homogène parallèlement aux dispositions
de droits pénal matériel euh le droit
allemand euh de procédure pénale fixe
une multitude de règles juridiques
visant à lutter contre le terrorisme
sont particulièrement intéressantes à
cet égard les méthodes suivantes la
recherche policière par
recoupement la surveillance des
télécommunications le recours des agents
d'infiltration le fichage c'est-à-dire
l'enregistrement des données de contrôle
aux frontières et euh observation
pendant une durée supérieur à 24
heures je passe brièvement à la
législation relative à la police et au
maintien de l'ordre euh en Allemagne la
défense policière contre les menaces
terroristes incombe aux autorités de
police de lender ou dans certain casat à
l'Office fédéral de police criminelle
pour des questions spécifiques par
exemple la sûreté aérienne elle relève
de la police
fédérale la loi relative à l'Office
fédéral de police criminelle et à la
coopération entre la Fédération et les
lenders en matière de police criminelle
définit des compétences spécifiques à la
défense face aux menaces que fait peser
le terrorisme
international
je passe brièvement à la Loi sur les
passeport et aussi la Loire sur les
cartes
d'identité
euh il est clair que les compatements
étrangers doivent être concrètement
empêchés de quitter le pays selon la loi
du sur les passeports un ressortissant
allemand peut se voir interdire la
sortie du territoire en cas de menace
pour la sécurité nationale ou encore
pour protéger d'autres intérêts
fondamentau de la République fédérale
cela se traduit alors par le retrait du
passeport toute personne quittant le
territoire national malgré le retraite
de son passeport et possible de sanction
fixé par la loi sur les
passeports une disposition de laallur
sur les cartes d'identité autorise
également les autorités compétentes à
ordonneré que dans des cas particuliers
la carte d'identité ne puisse pas être
utilisé pour quitter le territoire
allemand un projet de loi amendant la
loi sur les cartes d'identité en vu
d'introduire un document tenant lieu de
carte d'identité ainsi que la loi sur
les passeports a été approuvée par le
gouvernement fédéral en janvier cette
année en créant une nouvellep
justifiant le refus et le retrait de la
carte d'identité il vise à empêcher les
personnes suspectées d'être des
terroristes extrémistes d'effectuer des
déplacements qui représenteraient une
menace pour la protection de
l'État ainsi à l'instar du passeport la
délivrance d'une carte d'identité pourra
désormais être refusée ou la carte tre
retirée et afin de permettre un contrôle
efficace des interdictions de sortie du
territoire la personne concernée se
verra délivrer un document tenant lieu
de carte d'identité
elle ne sera ainsi plus autorisée à
quitter l'Allemagne
ensuite il a des dispositions prévues
par la loi relative au séjour des
étrangers en
Allemagne l'article 54 de la loi
relative au séjour des étrangers en
Allemagne pré l'expulsion des citoyens
étrangers y compris de l'Union
européenne soutenant appartenant ou
ayant
appartenu à une organisation terroriste
ainsi que ceux ayant commis des actions
teroriste au terme du code pénal selon
cette même loi un étranger peut se voir
interd dire la sortie sur le territoire
allemand
euh un M sur l'interdiction de créer des
associations au terme de la loi des
associations le minist le ministre
fédéral de l'Intérieur a prononcé une
interdiction d'activité visant plus
particulièrement l'État islamique toute
forme de soutien à l'état islamique est
donc désormais interdite et passible de
sanction
pénale finalement une prêve vue sur
d'autres champs d'action dans la lutte
contre le
terrorisme créé en 2004 le centre commun
pour la lutte antiterroriste fait office
du Bureau de coordination entre les
autorités de sécurité de l'État fédéral
et celle de lender et a pour vocation
d'accroître l'efficacité de la
répression du terrorisme
islamiste euh l'Office fédéral pour la
protection de la Constitution le Service
fédéral de
renseignement l'Office fédéral de police
criminelle la poli police fédérale le
service de sécurité militaire l'Office
criminel des des douanes le parquet
fédéral l'Office fédéral d'immigration
et des réfugiés ainsi que 16 offices
régionaux pour la protection de la
Constitution travail en étroite
colloporation au sein de C de ce centre
créé spécialement à cette fin à
Berlin deuxèe volet les fichiers
antiterroriste les fichiers
informatiques commun au service de
police et au service de renseign ne sont
restreints à des domaines concernant des
phénomènes bien précis et ont un contenu
strictement
limité des fichiers antiterroristes ont
été instaurés pour le terrorisme
international en 2007 38 autorité de
sécurité de l'État fédéral et des
linders coopèent par cet instrument ces
fichiers permettent de voir dans un
premier temps à propos de quels
individus organisations et cetera on en
lien avec le terrorisme international
les autres organismes disposent déjà
d'informations des informations
détaillées peuvent ensuite être obtenus
sur la demande direct directement via le
fichier et ou être échangé par d'autres
voies en application des dispositions
légales en vigueur concernant la
transmission de
renseignement dernier volet l'Internet
sert de plus en plus de plateforme de
propagande et de laboratoire d'idées aux
au islamistes ainsi que de moyens de
communication pour les raisons
teroristes islamistes le centre internet
commun a été créé aussi en 2007 à Berlin
en réponse à cette réalité les
représentants des autorités de sécurité
associé dans ce projet ont pour mission
de surveiller exploiter et analyser les
publications à contenu islamiste ou
djihadistes sur Internet afin
d'identifier le plus tôt possible les
des structures et activités extrémistes
et terroristes en ligne et pour
développer des contremesures je vous
remercie de votre attention et c'était
un discours tout à fait différent celui
qu'on avait avant plutôt technocrate
merci beaucoup merci merci beaucoup
Monsieur le Consul alors écoutez pour
pour l'organisation de de nos débats
excellence si vous le si vous le
permettez nous allons poser toutes les
questions en même temps et comme ça
chacun d'entre vous pourra donner soit
une réponse collective soit une une
réponse individuelle mais ce sera plus
simple il nous reste un peu plus de
d'une demi-heure donc on on va quand
même avoir le temps le temps de débattre
et ce ne sont pas les questions qui
manquent même si dans chacun de vos
programmes il y a des points évidents de
de convergence euh il n'en demeure pas
moins que l'absence d'Europe et de
coopération semble quand même
relativement relativement importante bon
évidemment nous n'avons pas abordé le
problème du renseignement euh euh mais
nous sommes nous sommes partis les uns
et les autres de de différentes
assemblées parlementaires je vois notre
collègue Jacques lejendre qui est
rapporteur à l'Assemblée parlementaire
du Conseil de l'Europe d'un rapport sur
le terrorisme même à l'Assemblée
parlementaire de l'OTAN j'ai aussi un
rapport sur le financement du terrorisme
nous avons quand même des assemblées qui
essayent de de travailler et et nous
avons néanmoins des des législations
très différentes pour pour beaucoup pour
beaucoup de raisons donc moi ma ma
première question ma question va être la
question de la surveillance des réseaux
financiers les petits et les grands quel
moyen avez-vous mis en place ou
allez-vous mettre en place pour
contrôler les flux financiers qui sont
pas forcément des flux importants mais
qui peuvent être des flux modestes comme
des crédits à la
consommation par exemple euh étant
entendu que
euh Western Union FedEx et tout ce genre
de de de de système de d'argent
dématérialisé constitue aussi des
éléments qui permettent de soutendre une
activité là encore ce ne sont pas des
sommes importantes ce sont des des
petites des petits ruisseaux qui qui
font les grandes rivières et je vais
passer la parole au au rapporteur merci
madame la Présidente je vais aussi être
succin je voulais vous dire madamees et
Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
combien j'ai été touché par tout ce que
vous avez dit et combien j'ai pu
remarquer quand même beaucoup de
convergence dans les préoccupations et
les mesures qui sont prises en œuvre qui
sont mises en œuvre dans les différents
pays madame la l'ambassadrice du
Danemark comment ne pas aimer la le
plédoyer que vous avez fait magnifique
pour la liberté et comment ne pas penser
que nous aimons tous tellement cette
liberté qu'il nous faut prendre des
mesures pour sauvegarder la liberté
contre ceux qui n'aiment pas la liberté
et qui n'aiment même pas qui n'aiment
pas la liberté de vivre d'autrui et à
cet
égard c'est vrai c'est le paradoxe
finalement les démocraties sont faibles
par rapport au terroristes parce que
nous savons bien que la plus grande
victoire des terroristes serait de nous
faire abandonner nos principes
démocratiques notre liberté et cetera en
même temps nous devons nous protéger
alors mes questions sont les suivantes
euh je crois comme madame la Présidente
qu'il y a tellement de convergence que
il faut certainement plus d'Europe
premièrement est je crois que est-ce que
vous êtes tous d'accord sur la nécessité
absolue que l'on ait le PNR c'est-à-dire
que l'on puisse avoir euh vraiment un
dispositif qui permettent de contrôler
les les flux
aériens deuxièmement euh par rapport euh
à la
déradicalisation c'estàd que tout le
monde dit il y a des discours radicaux
euh il faut lutter contre ces
discours que faire c'est pas si simple
quand quelqu'un a des choses dans la
tête d'arriver à ce qu'il pense
autrement donc
concrètement comment voyez-vous cela
très précisément on a parlé de l'école
on a parlé du contrôle des imams des
mosquées en même temps bien entendu nous
ne pouvons pas suspecter quelqu'un parce
qu'il les musulmans heureusement la
l'immense majorité des musulmans
condamne le terroriste mais comment
faire pour lutter contre cette
radicalisation par un discours ou par
pour persuader que c'est la mauvaise
voix et enfin ma dernière question sera
sur
l'Internet finalement tout le monde
prend tous les États sont amenés à
prendre des mesures sur l'Internet
monsieur l'ambassadeur du Royaume-Uni
vous avez dit nous dialogons avec les
les responsables les les ceux qui qui
qui ont des des accès hein les les les
les majur bon mais en même temps nous
prenons des mesures d'interdiction en
France on a pris une mesure
d'interdiction par rapport à certains
sites à certains messages xénophobe
raciste apologie du terrorisme et cetera
est-ce qu'il vous paraît possible
d'aller vers des règles européennes en
cette matière parce que moi il y a une
chose que je n'accepterai jamais je l'ai
déjà dit 100 fois mais je le dis pour la
101e fois en m'excusant devant mes
collègues c'est que Internet soit un
espace de non droit il y a des lois dans
tous les pays et on ne peut pas dire
dans nos pays il y a des lois elles
marchent sauf sur Internet ù ça ne
marche pas donc est-ce que on pourrait
imaginer des règles européennes par
rapport à Internet parce que le problème
est mondial et bien entendu même s'il y
a une règle européenne peut-être qu'il y
aura un site dans une île
exotique où on violera la règle
européenne mais si l'Europe se met
d'accord sur des les règles peut-être
qu'on pourra parler au monde à l'ONU et
cetera qu'on sera fort pour que Internet
ne soit pas un espace de non droit voilà
mes
questions
bien euh j'ai trois demandes de parole
madame Giselle
Jourda il y a un micro tu appuies le
rouge voilà
voilà tout d'abord tout d'abord donc
exprimer donc l'émotion que j'ai eu en
entendant donc les prises de parole de
tous nos ambassadeurs présents dans
cette salle parce que on a senti battre
le cœur de l'Europe cette Europe qu'on a
tendance à décrier bien souvent et à
rendre responsable de tous les mots on a
vu comme l'a dit madame la Présidente
cette convergence des dispositifs mis en
œuvre dans chaque pays pour justement
lutter contre le terrorisme et pour
faire que cette liberté de vivre sur un
sol soit préservée et c'est ce que nous
nous devons de faire donc après l'Europe
économique va venir cette Europe donc
politique malheureusement elle va être
davantage perceptible par rapport aux
douleurs que nous avons vécu début
janvier et que nous amis donc danois
viennent de vivre avec des expressions
différentes mais toujours très violentes
donc à cette violence aujourd'hui il
nous faut répondre et certes cette
Europe doit être en capacité d'apporter
les dispositifs pour enrayer donc cet
état de fait que je ne qualifieraiis ni
de bien ni de mal mais que je
qualifierai simplement de maladie à
exterminer tout simplement puisque nous
ne pouvons pas donc voir ce fléo se
répandre dans tous nos pays donc
d'Europe et même sur le plan
international alors moi j'ai été très
intéressé notamment par tout ce qui
touche la mise en place du PNR bien sûr
et surtout à se dire que nous pouvions
peut-être prendre
donc cette fois-ci la voix d'une
harmonisation des dispositifs et ne pas
être frileux sur ce qui peut faire
l'identité des et des autres puisque je
crois que l'identité européenne doit
surpasser cela et j'ai entendu dans les
propos donc de Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
donc de Grande-Bretagne qu'il y avait
dans les dispositifs mis en place la
nomination d'un coordinateur national
par rapport au terrorisme ce sont des
méthodes qu'on peut peut-être voir se
généraliser de manière donc à pouvoir
être efficace et ne pas chacun dans son
pays tenter d'inventer le choix alors
qu'il y a des dispositifs qui sont en
capacité de pouvoir répondre à certaines
questions j'achèverai sur euh
l'ouverture la modification de Schengen
je crois que c'est quelque chose qui
s'impose à nous de voir comment
justement on peut euh dans la
conjoncture actuelle pour justement
répondre à la
menace n'hésitons pas à modifier
peut-être quelque chose qui nous
paraissait être quelque chose de porteur
il y a quelques années en arrière après
nous nous nous serons toujours à atts de
rectifier le tir lorsque la paix aura
regagné donc notre sphère européenne et
que nous aurons vu ce fléo
indiguer en tout cas je le
souhaite merci merci beaucoup pour votre
pour votre intervention ça justifie tout
à fait la demande que nous avions faite
d'ouvrir cette audition au aux
parlementaires qui ne font pas partie de
la commission d'enquête et merci en tous
les cas de l'attention que vous avez
porté à notre à notre commission j'ai
une d'autre demande de parole de Michel
foruissier merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais à mon tour remercier madames et
Messieurs les Ambassadeurs pour la
clarté de leurs propos et puis on va
dire je suis rassuré par le réflexe des
démocraties par rapport à une atteinte
du terrorisme du djihadisme en
particulier qui veut bien entendu
s'attaquer au concept même de de la
démocratie et je souscris parfaitement à
propos également que vous avez émis
ainsi que ceux de notre rapporteur moi
je m'exprime en tant que sénateur membre
de la commission d'enquête et puis
également maire et élu de
l'agglomération lyonnaise la métropole
lyonnaise qui connaît des des problèmes
on va dire où certains élus veulent
expliquer la montée du djihadisme par
des problèmes de crise et de manque de
travail ou de cohésion social et on se
rend compte qu'au
Danemark c'est pas la même problématique
du tout donc je crois que le phénomène
il faut le chercher vraiment dans ses
sources et moi aussi qui suis un
Européen
convaincu je pense que la réponse de
chaque État ne sera pas suffisante si on
n pas capable de mettre en place une
réponse européenne avec une coordination
européenne et des échanges de R
enseignement systématique de nos
différents coordinations nationales
puisqu'il y en a maintenant je pense
dans tous les pays européens qui sont
touchés par ce phénomène et comme
pensez-vous madames et Messieurs les
Ambassadeurs qu'on peut y aller jusque
là bien
qu'évidemment pour moi ça nécessite de
faire une avancée politique européenne
c'est peut-être l'occasion justement de
ne pas IR sur not espace de liberté
européen à la fois d'échange des libre
circulation des hommes et et des
produits on va dire pour simplifier on
va pas rentrer dans dans le détail on
connaît tous ces textes et ces
références par cœur et on n pas le temps
de refaire ce débat mais est-ce que
c'est pas justement l'occasion
d'assujétir cette espace de liberté à
une espace de protection je ne parle pas
même de répression parce que je consid
que ceux qui tombent dans le système du
djihadisme sont aussi les premières
victimes donc je crois que est-ce que
c'est possible à votre avis de faire à
cette occasion d'un traumatisme
international fort est-ce que c'est pas
l'occasion ou jamais de faire une
nouvelle avancée vers la construction
européenne merci alain GOURNAC pour
terminer je voudrais effectivement dire
que j'étais très satisfait d'entendre
les représentants des pays amis de
France parce que le problème il nous est
pas réservé nous vons de voir dans un
pays que je connais bien qu le pays que
vous représentez madame
et je pense qu'il y a des idées et que
ces idées nous pourvons les échanger
hein il y a des alors il y a des
spécificités mais il y a des idées qui
sont en général tout à fait
intéressantes parce que nous nous allons
avoir des propositions à faire le final
de notre travail alors ma première
question va vers le le monsieur
l'Ambassadeur de GrandeBretagne vous
avez dit oui monsieur c'est pour vous le
nombre d'imam vous avez beaucoup d'imam
qui vont dans les prisons parce que vous
avez dit y a un nombre d'omoners mais
est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup
dans les prisons nous on vient visiter
une prison française il pas beaucoup
est-ce qu'il y a les imams et puis vous
avez parlé d'agent d'agents dans les
prisons alors je pense que c'est des
agents de renseignement ah vous n'avez
pas
ah bon parce que nous on a on est en
train de pousser des des agents qui
sont l'administration pénitentiaire de
façon à nous donner c'est pareil que
vous bon pour de façon à nous donner des
des ma deuxème question c'est à
l'ensemble de nos amis ambassadeurs
est-ce que vos pays acceptent que les
lieux de culte soient financé par des
pays étrangers quelle est votre position
sur cela c'est-à-dire est-ce que
d'autres pays peuvent payer et puis à
vous euh madame l'ambassadrice
euh on a bien sûr été extrêmement touché
par ce qui s'est passé ça peut vous dire
c'est comme si c'était chez nous hein je
vous dire exactement pareil quand on a
quand j'ai entendu les choses mais on a
vu qu'il y avait une grande
manifestation si nous aussi on a une
grande manifestation mais madame on a vu
aussi qu'il y avait une manifestation
pro pro euh le le le pour soutenir
précisément le tueur
est-ce qu'il y a de législation dans
votre pays qui va réagir et puis nous
avons entendu alors sur plusieurs radios
des jeunes qui étaient de ce quartier je
pense hein je crois qui nous expliquait
combien il fallait absolument soutenir
ce genre de chose quel est votre quelle
est la la la possibilité de la justice
de votre pays qui un grand pays de la
liberté vis-à-vis de cette manifestation
et vis-à-vis de ce ces déclarations j'en
ai vu trois ou quatre je qui dont même
un s'exprimait parfaitement en français
et nous expliquait bien qu'il fallait
soutenir ce ce système de dihadiste
voilà merci madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup alors le le
grand privilège de la présidence c'est
de commencer à poser des questions c'est
aussi de poser la dernière j'attendais
que mes collègues se manifestent
j'aurais donc une une dernière question
collective je dirais est-ce que vous
avez chacun dans votre pays respectif un
établissement de formation des imam
parce que une des une des
préoccupations on a parlé de financement
des lieux de culte mais on a aussi un
problème de formation alors les les nos
amis britanniques ont réglé le problème
en imposant les prêches en anglais ce
n'est pas encore tout à fait fait chez
nous et et nous avons évidemment des
imames et et des et des homoniers qui
qui ne sont pas des nationaux et qui
comme comme le dit très joliment
euh le le
responsable de formation en
France il faut mettre le texte dans le
contexte c'est-à-dire la religion dans
le contexte du pays dans lequel elle
s'exprime je vous remercie et je vous
laisse la parole monsieur l'ambassadeur
de Grande-Bretagne vous vous
commencez merci beaucoup madame et merci
Monsieur Madame les sénateurs pour pour
l'intérêt que vous avez porté et pour
les question euh très très pertinent et
je vais essayer de répondre à plusieurs
euh mais je laisse le soin de mes
collègues de répondre au plus difficile
c'est probablement comme ça que ça doit
marcher euh
euh sur les renseignements on ne peut
pas dire grand-chose bien sûr mais je
peux parler en tant de excoordinateur de
renseignement je peux assurer les euh
les sénateurs présents que il y a une
excellente coordination entre les
services européens mais c'est en dehors
du cadre de l'Union européenne disons
comme ça c'est pas dans la compétences
EUR européenne mais ça existe et ça
marche bien et c'est absolument
essentiel que ça marche bien dans le
cadre de l'Union européenne nous sommes
absolument en faveur d'un PNR et un prnr
qui permet l'échange de d'information
sur les vols
intraeuropéens bien sûr c'est urgent je
sais que la France en fait une quand
même et nous aussi mais c'est beaucoup
mieux que ça se fait au niveau européen
une autre chose qu'il faut faire au
niveau européen c'est tr les armes et
lutter lutter contre les disponibilité
d'armes lourd qui est essentiel aussi
euh quelqu'un a fait mention au flux
financier je ne suis pas un expert mais
je sais qu'il y a des moyens de de
tracer les flux financiers peut-être pas
madame la sénatrice sénateur
suffisamment fine pour avoir des petits
flous chez nous un un moyen qu'on
utilise c'est les proscription de
certains euh groupes terroristes si on
les proscrire à à ce moment-là on peut
poursuivre leur leur financement aussi
éviter qu'il collectent les fonds par
exemple un mot
sur les
omoniers chez nous oui effectivement
nous avons davantage d'omoners dans les
prisons que que c'est le cas en France
et nous les payons je ne suis pas
certain que nous les formons nous
exigeons comme vous dites madame qui qui
prêche en anglais mais nous avons ça je
j'essayie de faire au personnel
pénitentiaire que nous formons pour être
vigilant pour les signes de comportement
suspect ou ou à risque mais aussi nous
avons un petit structure aussi de de de
renseignement de ce qui se passe dans
les prisons parce que dans les prisons
c'est un vrai pépinière de
radicalisation je pense dans tous nos
pays alors c'est c'est dans dans
l'intérêt de tout le monde un dernier
mot de ma part sur l'Internet et
j'entends et je comprends prend bien les
appels pour légiférer au niveau européen
sur
l'Internet notre expérience à Londres
c'est que on peut pas avoir on peut
avoir un bon accord un bon partenariat
avec ces grands fournisseurs d'accès au
internet ces grands acteurs
euh au niveau volontaire plutôt que
qu'avoir recours à la législation je
donne par
exemple la façon dont il ils ont réagi à
la pédophilie euh là les les grandes
sociétés de l'internet ont bien agi pour
lutter contre la pédophilie en ligne et
nous pensons que on peut travailler avec
eux aussi contre les sites radicals euh
et les la matériel contenu radical en
ligne nous avons depuis 2010 travaillé
là-dessus nous avons fait supprimer
72000 site ou ou contenu euh radical en
ligne je n'exclue pas du tout la L é de
législation mais ça peut être long et
compliqué et dans le court terme il faut
travailler en accord avec ces sociétés
qui quand même ils ont leur valeur leur
normes ils sont capables à accepter que
ce n'est pas bon pour leur business de
d'éberger les terroristes ou ou les gens
qui prêchent le radicalisme alors
travaillant en en volontariat peut-être
avec la législation en derniers recours
si nécessaire merci beaucoup et pour le
financement des financement étrangers
pour les lieux
cultes ça je ne sais pas je mon collègue
expert plus ex moi dit oui plutôt
monsieur
lesateur merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur des Pays-Bas à
vous merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
euh quelques réponses aux questions qui
ont été soulevées évidemment on a parlé
de la coopération européenne ça existe
heureusement euh et on sait pas tout
heureusement
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de
contact entre les services concernés ça
c'est c'est clair en plus il y a les
réunions de nos collègues à Bruxelles
alors sur ce plan là je crois que on
fait déjà le nécessaire sans qu'on soit
forcément au courant de ce qui se passe
tous les jours pour les questions de de
finan bon je ne peux que parler pour les
Pays-Bas bien sûr mais on a créé chez
nous ce qu'on appelle une financial
Intelligence Unit unité sur le
renseignement financier qui est une
contribution sur le plan national et
international en ce qui concerne le
financement de de terrorisme et cette
institution cet organisme partage des
renseignements
confidenciels avec des banques et des
des enfin comme vous AZ dit Western
Union et cetera pour leur mettre dans
une position de reconnaître des
transactions qui sont peut-être
suspectes alors sur ce planlà il y a
quand même des mesures assez concrètes
qui ont été prises deuxè point les imams
il y en a dans la prison
euh enfin je tiens quand même à le dire
on trouve des omonés des imams il y a
SEP en fait religions qui sont prés
représenté dans la prison les
protestants les catholiques islamistes
humanistes Juifs bouddhistes et
hindouiste alors ceement là euh je crois
queon a fait le nécessaire et il y en a
qui sont
enfin payé par l'État il y a des imames
dans les prisons payés par l'État et
d'ailleurs il y a aussi des islams
euh dans l'armée bien sûr alors sur ce
planlà on fait le nécessaire euh et là
je crois que il enfin ça aide vraiment à
accompagner les les détenus qui sont qui
sont dans la prison d'ailleurs c'est une
processus qui est fortement réglementé
vous vous imaginez euh 3è point qui a
été soulevé bien sûr c'est la prévention
le contrediscours euh j'en ai dit
quelques mots dans mon introduction tout
à l'heure je voudrais quand même
souligner que le travail le plus
important ici est à faire par les
communes euh il y a le maire euh qui
était là de de de d'une des euh des
villes tout près de Lyon euh mais là
effectivement le travail se fait euh
c'est dans les communes euh dans avec
une coopération très étroite bien sûr
avec enfin le maire les élus euh les
gens qui font l'éducation et et là comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure on met à la
disposition de ces communes des moyens
financiers aussi euh pour avoir des
programmes aussi sur internet pour
expliquer ce qui se passe et pour tenir
aussi ce contre contreiscours
euh par exemple et là je cite quelques
mesures qui ont été prises euh on donne
l'information sur la façon dont les
jeunes sont recrutés hein pour pour
expliquer aux gens euh ce qui s'est fait
ce qui évidemment pour expliquer aussi
l'un danger qui qui vontent avec ce ce
processus euh on veut démasquer les
initiatives des manipulations euh qui
sont faites pour convaincre les gens
d'une idéologie qui est bien sûr très
dangereuse et un troisième point que qui
tombe sur cette activité là
euh évidemment on on veut montrer les
expériences négatives de gens qui sont
partis et qui qui sont peut-être rentrés
au Pays-Bas il on veut montrer aussi aux
jeunes qu'est-ce que cela veut dire si
vous partez euh faire la lutte et cetera
euh ailleurs alors tout ça fait partie
de ce contre contreiscours évidemment on
essaie de faire ça avec dans une
coopération euh très étroite euh entre
la communauté musulmane et les autorités
concernés et et on cherche vraiment
aussi à ils ont appuyé les initiatives
de ce communauté musulmane pour leur
appuyer dans leur démarche parce que
c'est encore mieux si eux le font
eux-mêmes pour dire aux gens aux jeunes
et cetera attention c'est dangereux il
faut pas il faut pas se tromper sur ce
qui se passe et cetera euh et là je
crois que bon c'est la la façon enfin
disons les moyens les les plus
importantes pour éviter que il y a ce ce
réseau ce sol nourriissier qui qui est
là qui n'est pas uniquement là pour
recruter des gens on pourra avoir aussi
disons une une une une une environnement
propice à à à la discours djihadiste et
cetera merci
beaucoup il nous reste le financement
des lieux de culte
oui ça existe bah on l'interdit pas on
accepte d'autre chose mais on ninterdit
pas voilà merci merci beaucoup Monsieur
l'ambassadeur d'Espagne à vous merci
madame je vais être très bref sur les
contrôles des flux financiers et nous
avons un mécanisme qui s'appelle C black
et qui est se ressemble énormément et
presque identique au au trackfing que
vous avez ici en France presque
identique et ça fonctionne au même temps
et avec cette réforme du du code pénal
dont j'avais parlé dans mon intervention
il y a une modification prévue de
l'article
76 précisément pour identifier les les
les délis de flux irrégulier des
financiers et enfin pour établir des
peines et dans dans les nouveaux codes
pénal aussi pour ce qui est
de du financement des des mosquées
oui les
les
l'État permet des pays étrangers
financer des mosquées en Espagne
d'ailleurs il n'y a qu'un pays qui a
financé les mosquées nous les
connaissons tous si vous voulez nous les
nommons hein c'est l'Arabie Saoudite
hein mais il y a un contrôle ça veut
dire que on autorise le financement des
mosquées mais pas l'établissement des
mosquées partout hein tout simplement
dans des endroits où la population
musulmane est significative chose qui
évid n'est pas évidente dans beaucoup
d'endroits où nos amisudiens ont voulu
financer des
mosquées et aussi pour les imans nous
n'avons pas des formation d'Iman mais
nous sommes très attentifs aux imans qui
sont qui travaille au pressionon on
essaie de de trouver les plus modérés et
les plus raisonnables évidemment nous
avons la liste d'im radical ils sont
tous écartés des
prisons merci
pardonnez-moi mais mais vous écartez les
plus radicaux mais vous
avez des des imams vous
avez du personnel musulman à l'intérieur
de votre ministère de l'Intérieur qui
permet de dire quelle est le bon imam du
mauvais parce que si vous n'avez pas de
formation nous n'en avons pas non plus
comment comment vous sélectionnez les
imams qui vont notamment en prison ça
c'est une vraie difficulté moi je crois
madame la Présidente j'ai l'impression
que les services de renseignement
espagnol s'occupe de ça et et de façon
très sérieuses hein et je crois qu'ils
sont tous identifiés évidemment notre
tâche est plus simple que la vôtre parce
que les nombre de musulmans en Espagne
n'atteint pas les les les nombres de
musulmans en France mais de toute façon
il y en a euh il y en a presque un
million de musulmans en Espagne et ils
sont les services des renseignements
sont très très bien
euh informés de ce qui se passe dans les
communautés musulmanes précisément parce
que nous savons que ça c'est le
radicalisme dans les dans dans dans les
mosquées et les madraassas les écoles
c'est vraiment les germes de tout le
terrorisme islamiste euh islamique alors
évidemment les les gens qui vont sont
envoyés au prisson sont des gens qui ont
déjà été déjà passé des filtres et qui
ont été identifiés comme des gens
risonnable la la réponse qui consiste à
dire les services de renseignement me
semble une très bonne réponse mais je
crois que N nos amis britannique ont eux
embauché des imams au sein de du home
office de façon à à faire la
sélection ce qui m'avait été comme
consultant voilà ce qui était ce qui
était aussi une une option la Présidente
je pense que nos deux ambassadeurs des
Royaume-Uni des Pays-Bas ont bien dit
qu'ils étaient pour le PNR tout à
l'heure et pour l'Espagne pour les
Pays-Bas vous êtes pour c'est c'est les
plus forts défenseur du P le PNR
l'Espagne est le plus fort défenseur et
Monsieur mon l'ambassadeur pour les
Pays-Bas même chose merci beaucoup hein
madame l'ambassadrice du du Danemark à
vous merci faites-nous rêver merci merci
madame la Présidente je vais me
concentrer sur le point où j'espère être
utile pour cette débat alors PNR le
Danemark est pour mais le conseil comme
vous le savez n'est pas le problème
c'est le Parlement et ça persiste ça
persiste
même après Charlie et et c'est ça le le
problème euh
euh surveillance de de Réau financiers
c'est très très intéressant comme comme
vous tous euh nous avons aussi
euh quelque chose comme le Financial
Intelligence Unit et ça marche très bien
mais est-ce que on pose des vraies
questions parce que une des lesçons je
crois c'est trop tôt à le dire mais une
des question de questions on peut tirer
des des des attentats des copenhag c'est
que il y a des liens entre le banditisme
et la
radicalisation il y a même des liens
entre les délis banales et la
radicalisation et si on ne pose pas le
des questions correctes on ne regarde
pas ce qu'il se passe vraiment même si
on a des outils parce que ce qui est en
libre circulation malheureusement c'est
de l'argent et des
armes
Schengen on est en train d'étudier avec
beaucoup
beaucoup de créativité comme juriste
parce qu'il faut vraiment être un
juriste créatif pour
trouver comment est-ce que Schengen peut
être utilisé dans des cas extrêmes comme
nous vivons pour le moment et on
n'espère pas comme européen que Schengen
est vraiment quelque chose qui est
presque anachronique de notre temps et
ça c'est une étude que que ont fait à
Copenhague et
peut-être exactement pour défendre
Europe ça ça doit être une étude queon
puisse faitre faire ensemble parce que
sinon c'est les
eurosceptiques qui qui vont utiliser ça
comme comme argument entre contre euh la
libre circulation des des personnes et
espécialement Schengen Schengen c'est
c'est un problème mais mais on croit
qu'il y a des solution mais il faut
vraiment être pas trop trop
orthodoxe l'éducation d'imam une autre
question très très pertinent on a
discuté ça longtemps au Danemark on a on
a réfléchi très concrètement de le faire
même en en 2003 une fois encore en 2013
mais c'est difficile c'est très très
difficile parce qu'il faut êre êre en
dialogue même pas avec les les les imams
ou
ou les étudiants d'Islam à Copenhague
mais aussi d'autres
pays euh mais maintenant on sait que il
y a une grande majorité de la population
au Danemark qui dit exactement ça qu'il
faut avoir cette éducation et et si euh
je je fais la l'ugmentation que ce qui
fait vraiment le le ADN du Danemark
c'est
l'éducation ça s'applique bien sûr aussi
concernant l'imam et comme comme en Pays
Bas il il y a des imam dans les
pressions payé par l'État euh mais mais
ça ne veut pas dire que ils sont
vraiment les sources a les sources avec
l'autorité euh euh en pression c'est
c'est notre monde c'est notutre culture
il faut être là et très très proche
euh plus d'Europe oui peut-être et c'est
pas parce que parce que il y a toujours
49 % de danois qui sont un peu réticents
pas du tout c'est c'est c'est c'est
notre côté très
pragmatique c'est facile de dire plus
d'Europe mais quoi parce que les
solutions se trouve
souvent très très près des milieux où
on produit entre guillemets euh des des
terroristes alors c'est des solutions
locaux ou local c'est c'est c'est ça
qu'il faut euh vraiment étudier bien sûr
ensemble bien sûr ensemble sur
l'Internet nous nous sommes d'accord
merci et le financement des lieux de
culte madame l'ambassadeur oui on
accepte aussi que que c'est fait par par
des pays étrangers merci merci beaucoup
voilà pour cette table ronde de droit
comparés qui s'était tenu le 17 février
2015 dans le cadre des travaux de la
commission d'enquête sur la lutte contre
les réseaux djihadistes commission
d'enquête présidée par Nathalie Goulet
sénatrice udi UC et dont le rapporteur
était le sénateur socialiste Jean-Pierre
chur une table ronde que nous vous avons
proposé de suivre dans dans le contexte
du terrible attentat de Nice qui s'est
tenu hier et à la suite duquel et bien
manuel Vals a annoncé 3 jours de deuil
national qui débuteront demain vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les auditions sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
les chaînes
parlementaires